welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farin cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today
the dixie fire ravaging out there
in the state of california this week
essentially swallowed up an entire town
the town of greenville
it was an old mining town has been
around for ages small population
estimated to be about 1200 and that fire
absolutely incinerated and destroyed the
downtown of this area
the dixie fire and of course many homes
and all of that
the town is destroyed much like paradise
was
several years ago with that wildfire and
now we have another town
that is on the verge of not even
existing
because of this fire dixie fire has been
raging for three weeks now
and it is just one of what one of my
numbers here
one of 97 wildfires
currently in the united states across 13
different states
we have 97 wildfires right now ravaging
the united states
20 000 active firefighters out there
trying to put out the flames
this is climate change let's be honest
the heat dome that we saw over the
pacific northwest
earlier this summer that's climate
change
we have such extreme temperatures over
on the west coast the northern west
coast
that we've literally had billions of sea
creatures
that have died because of the extreme
change in the water temperature
and to make matters worse with the dixie
fire and other fires
we're having another weather event you
know
strong gusting winds you know 30 40
miles an hour
that is making it difficult for
firefighters to be able to get there
and of course it's making it easier for
the fire to spread
and based on the reporting that i've
seen it does appear
that this fire much like the one that
destroyed the town of paradise
um was possibly started by faulty
equipment from california energy company
p g and e
this one they're saying they're they
believe there was a branch
laying on a piece of equipment that
could have sparked
and then caused the fire um obviously
it's it's a little too soon to uh
you know make bold accusations as to you
know pg e was definitely at fault for
this
first we got to work on getting the
flames out we've got to conduct the
investigations we've got to figure out
what exactly is happening here
so that's what's being reported again
can't necessarily make one claim one way
or another
but what we do have to acknowledge the
claim we can make
is that extreme events like this
all of these fires not just the dixie
fire
this is what climate change looks like
we have watched all through 2021 to be
honest with you
as climate change isn't knocking at our
door
it's bursting through that door and
saying
i am here
winter storm yuri in texas that was
climate change
saying here i am look at me
the heat dome here i am the fires
that of course result from the droughts
and the extreme heat
i am here is what climate change is
telling us
now we have an administration now
that understands this we just went four
years with an administration
that at one point had said that climate
change was a hoax by the chinese
and the trump administration actively
worked to roll
back environmental protections
emission reductions fuel efficiency
all for no other reason than he wanted
to
undo parts of president obama's
environmental legacy
and republicans cheered this stuff on
they were happy about it
oh boy he's repealing the the matte
standard
so there's going to be more mercury in
our
air they were happy about these things
but climate change is here i know
i know i know i know the study from 2018
saying we got 12 years until the worst
effects of climate change might not just
hit us but might also become the norm
well guess what that was three years ago
that that came out and we essentially
had three years
at that point and two years prior to
that of back pedaling on the issue of
climate change
emissions even though we had the
pandemic last year global emissions
actually still increased
we're not getting better yet
but we can there is still time
and with an administration that
understands the dangers of this
have they gone as far as i want them to
on the issue of climate change
absolutely not like
really not even close to what needs to
happen
but at least we're finally moving in the
right direction
and you can't be upset about that we can
be frustrated that we're not doing
everything that needs to be done yet
and that's why we keep pushing and
that's why we keep fighting